luego de meses de conflicto y tensiones
constantes el ejército eritreo acordó
retirar sus tropas de la disputada
región de tigre en el norte de etiopía
fronteriza con eritrea así lo anunció el
primer ministro etíope había hammett que
esta semana tras meses de negación
admitió la presencia de militares
eritreos en el territorio desde
noviembre de 2020 con la escalada de los
ataques cosmos el gobierno de eritrea ha
aceptado retirar sus tropas de la
frontera etíope la fuerza de defensa
nacional de etiopía se hará cargo de la
vigilancia de las zonas fronterizas con
efecto inmediato el premio nobel de la
paz etíope no informó de cuántos
soldados eritreos se movilizaron pero
testigos se estiman que podrían ser
miles además reconoció que durante los
enfrentamientos con las fuerzas rebeldes
tigrillas se cometieron crímenes de
guerra sin aceptar responsabilidades
tanto el ejército eritreo como el etíope
han sido señalados de saqueos masacres y
violaciones la gente fue asesinada por
las balas las armas pesadas con los
tanques disparaban y las casas fueron
quemadas en este momento de la gente
huyó si los atrapaban los mataban era el
ejército eritreo el que hacía
este viernes naciones unidas- consiguió
entrar a los campos de refugiados
eritreos en tigres por primera vez desde
noviembre durante una misión conjunta en
la zona con la oficina de coordinación
de asuntos humanitarios de la onu
encontramos ambos campamentos
completamente destruidos y todas las
instalaciones humanitarias saqueadas y
vandalizadas
acnur está profundamente preocupada por
el bienestar de los refugiados eritreos
que residían allí todos han huido de los
campos
el conflicto en etiopía estalló el
pasado 4 de noviembre desde entonces
casi un millón de etíopes y refugiados
eritreos han huido al vecino sudán